benjamins moi je voulais revenir sur ce
qui s'était dit sur les réseaux sociaux
depuis que sandra muller le 13 octobre a
lancé ce hashtag balances ton port
finalement on a on a noté presque 3 135
mille messages et on verra dans les
sujets suivants que c'est absolument
énorme sur sur cette période là alors
évidemment cette initiative et la
libérer la parole et révéler l'ampleur
de la souffrance
et quand on regarde la topographie des
messages qu'est ce qu'on voit on va
retrouver des témoignages d'agressions
et d'harcèlement
on va retrouver une mise en exergue du
sexisme ordinaire ou de la pression
subie par les femmes parfois les
témoignages de soutien et solidarité et
de solutions et ce qui est intéressant
c'est que ces messages 61% ont été
postées par des femmes avec sur les 40 %
restants
finalement des témoignages d'hommes qui
venait en soutien de ces messages de
femmes donc par là même sa rejoint
comment dire ce sondage que nous avons
réalisé hier où on disait que cette
question du harcèlement sexuel et des
agressions est un problème important
pour 91% des français
alors après la question véritablement
que ça pose c'est est-ce que internet et
les réseaux sociaux doit être une forme
de tribunal populaire parce que sur
l'ensemble de ces 335 milles message il
y a dix sept mille témoignages qui sont
des témoignages d'agressions et
d'harcèlement et parmi ceux-là seuls une
dizaine qu'on porte un nom alors est ce
que véritablement au delà d'avoir libéré
la parole on encourage la délation est
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que
terme de porc fait réagir c'est à dire
que il le révèle une forme de violence
et quand on regardait ce sondage où les
français sont très partagés et bien 43 %
d'entre eux disent oui à l'initiative
on la rejette justement pour cette
partie des lattes war et cette partie
juillet finalement à ce mot de porc et
en même temps